el agua gana decenas de metros en solo
unos segundos
y las carreteras son casi intransitables
solo algunos automovilistas se aventuran
a usarlas
ya en alerta máxima tras una fuerte
tormenta California se enfrenta ahora a
graves inundaciones
en Watsonville los residentes que han
decidido quedarse construyen
apresuradamente diques improvisados y
evalúan los daños iniciales
es muy muy triste y abrumador ver todo
lo que he perdido y no tengo seguro de
hogar contra inundaciones
el agua se detuvo aquí conseguí cerrar
los conductos de ventilación para que el
agua no entrara en la casa
en las estaciones de servicio muchos
adoptan la misma precaución llenan
bidones de gasolina
las retroexcavadoras trabajan en las
carreteras para despejar los escombros y
restablecer el flujo normal del tráfico
aquí ya hay un carril de dos habilitado
los equipos de rescate han estado
trabajando toda la noche árboles
tumbados sobre las casas
techos dañados calles cortadas la
tormenta también causó varias víctimas
uno de ellos era un niño pequeño